gentlemen this was a blast and before
the night is out one of you will be dead
my father's a tv comedy writer when i
said to him i want to go work on this
animated tv show he said you're nuts
don't ever do that you'll ruin your
career
i think everybody that's worked on it
has had the same view which is
this is a special thing you know the
highlight of my career and the career of
almost everybody that's been there and i
think you just go you don't want to let
people down
[Music]
to this day just such a magical writer's
room and we were
riding it in like a flop house literally
a place like like a heroin den
in a bad building
my wife brought our daughter it was like
two at the time they were wearing like
matching sun dresses and my wife that
night said like i'm never going there
what was i thinking
[Music]
just to show you how far the show has
come matt greening had a couple of ideas
first season for the end of the show
we've had a lot of episodes that could
have been great last episodes like
maggie talking like the uh behind the
music parody i think when it comes it
may just be something like that there's
a bunch of different ways you could end
you guys in your animation i just
thought of this
you can't get that on your simpson show
i thought of it and it happened
and now it's done
[Music]